non
elie wiesel se veut le gardien est le
garant de la mémoire des juifs c'est
cette fonction qui lui a valu le prix
nobel de la paix pour lui le moment est
venu de narrer sa vie pulsions légitime
chez un écrivain si ancrée dans le
siècle de voir soumis à une intemporel
obligations hier soir j'ai vu mon père
en rêve
il est venu me chercher écrit-il alors
et de tous les fleuves vont à la mer
publié au seuil enfants d'acheter tle de
bessarabie le village originel de tous
les juifs d'europe centrale
il est studieux et pieux marquée par la
renommée de son père est le sens de la
vie que lui donne sa grand mère obsédée
par dieu et bientôt par les femmes
il perçoit en l'alphabet le commencement
et la fin de toutes choses et pressent
la singularité de sa foi qui donnent
toute leur place à l'imagination à la
création à la littérature
vienne est inéluctable la déportation la
mort du père puis les études en france
et ce voyage en inde dont il mesure la
puissance spirituelle et dont il revient
le paradoxe n'est qu'apparent en plus
juif qu'avant dès lors vise elle est au
monde aux côtés de mendès-france et de
mauriac puis installé en amérique est il
écrit il écrit